andriy yarmolenko sera le fer de lance
de l'équipe ukrainienne
lors de l'euro 2016, cet attaquant du dynamo Kiev figure parmi les 23
sélectionnés pour ce championnat il a
joué tous les 34 matchs de la dernière
saison et avec 19 buts et 13 passes
décisives
il a décroché son troisième titre de champion d’Ukraine.
sa carrière en équipe nationale a commencé en 2009
et aujourd'hui les supporteurs placent beaucoup d'espoirs en lui pour cette compétition
Andriy Yarmolenko joue ailier droit mais il peut aussi bien jouer à gauche
ils se sent également à l'aise en attaque
Ainsi son entraîneur compte sur Yarmolenko pour fatiguer son adversaire
"Yarmola" comme l'appellent ses
supporteurs a toutes ses chances pour
devenir le nouveau "cheva" en
référence à Andreï Chevtchenko
en ce sens le ballon d'or 2004
a fait du lobbying pour son compatriote
auprès de l'équipe milanaise l'équipe
où il a terminé sa grande carrière
"j'ai dis au milan de regarder dans sa
direction" a déclaré récemment Andréï Chevtchenko
Yarmolenko a signé son contrat avec dynamo kiev jusqu'à 2020,
mais sans attendre ses résultats
pour l'euro 2016 quelques clubs
européens ont déjà manifesté leur
intérêt pour ce footballeur
selon les médias ukrainiens il s'agit
notamment de Liverpool et d'Arsenal
Yarmolenko a inscrit son nom dans
l'histoire du football ukrainien
comme le footballeur qui a marqué le
but le plus rapide en 2011 face à
l'uruguay il a ouvert le score à la 14e
seconde